Thank you all for coming with that.
If you could please help me welcome up.
Bill Skarsgard and Nadia Hilker
of their divergence. Here he is.
Hi everybody.
Hi. Hi. How are you? Good.
I'm nervous.
I'm really nervous.
You guys are so smart and awesome and
with, with that, welcome to Google. Thank
you. Thank you for Lucy. Are you good?
Thank you. [inaudible] and welcome to
Chicago. Uh, allegiant is, is that in,
in Chicago? I think the whole
divergence here. He says,
is this your first time here? I
was here as a baby. Oh, great time.
I know you're just in town for a
short time, but how are you liking it?
It's great. It's, the
food has been amazing.
The bed at the hotel is
mindblowing. Um, no, it's,
it's beautiful. Whatever. I could
see, you know, out of the car.
I definitely want to give back.
It's very strange because we were
in Philly, uh, yesterday, uh,
and we flew from a word,
both flow flew from La to Philly and you
land and then you do like you go to bed
and then you wake up in a different place
and you do all this press junket and
we'll do the same thing today.
And I was like sitting like last night
at the hotel. I'm like, where am I?
Like what time? What time was it? Where
am I? Like, who am I? So it's been,
it's been emotional,
huh?
Yeah, very emotional. He's
been crying all day. Oh, okay.
Hopefully you're feeling better now.
We're here for you.
Thank you. Thank you. That
makes a lot Google. Thank you.
But it is, it is great to have
you guys here were, were, um,
very proud of,
of being in Chicago and it's great to
see you guys representing the city on,
on the big screen.
That's like half my lines. It's
just Chicago. Protect Chicago.
Going back to Chicago.
There you go. There you go.
You're sending up for us by a,
are the characters that you play in the
series a bill, you'll play Matthew and,
uh, you play Nida and the,
they're new to the series.
What drew you guys to
want to play those actors?
Do you want to be in the divergent series?
Um, we got the job. Yeah. That's how
it works. You got the job and you go,
Yay. So much of a
choice. Um, no, but yeah,
you can go ahead.
Um, so, oh my God, there's
a lot to say about that.
Um,
first of all,
getting a part like that is so big,
especially being from Germany and, you
know, yeah. Don't get me started on that.
Then second, Nida is a beautiful
young, strong, powerful,
confident,
bad ass woman.
Didn't like take too much of,
you know, convincing me that. Um,
and then third, um, I really like
the, the, the, the, you know,
diversion in surgeon and I really
liked the message of those movies.
Um, so yeah, and then getting
the was just crazy.
Yeah, no, it's, it's, it's same for
me. Like, I'm from Stockholm, Sweden
and um, and um, yeah, you know,
it's, it's, it's just great.
You know, this is I guess,
but by far the biggest movie that either
one of us have been in. So just in,
just in terms of like the size and, and
you know, it's huge fan base and uh,
there's a lot of expectation
on it and like you,
you play characters that they're also
in the books and what not. So it's like,
it's very overwhelming. Um, and then
it was just like a great experience.
I'm just filming it,
shooting it and like meeting the cast
and it was a weird thing. Like we've,
we've been doing interviews so I can
just feel like I'm repeating myself over
and over again. But like we, um, we went
to, um, like it feels like you're going,
like, you're going like, you're
going to school for the first time,
but like a new school,
like you changed schools or whatever cause
like they get these guys on the posts
are like, they all knew
each other. They work for,
to like two done two movies together.
They have all these inside jokes and like
the first scene that I shot was, um, um,
um,
my character has his monologue.
He's walking down and he's
like introducing these guys
to the, the new, you know,
world outside of shoot Chicago.
Um,
and it's just me talking and it's like
500 extras staring at me while I'm doing
it because it's like, ah, it was this
whole ordeal and it was kind of nervous,
like nerve wracking and like they know
each other and they're like making all
these jokes and they're like friends
and you're like, hi, I'm bill.
All right. I mean, they're like, we
had each other. We were like, yeah,
we had each other. Yeah. But it's
helped so much. I was so happy then.
So you were the new kid is
you're the new guy. Yeah,
me too. Me Too. You want to be my
friend? Not, I don't have any choice.
I don't have any other day.
I love it. It's great. You know,
you guys are going all over the country
promoting the movie. Yeah. Yeah.
Making,
making that jump from European movies
and just other other movies to a big
Hollywood movie and a multipart series.
What was the most surprising
to you about the process?
The thing is I never made the jump,
not even at my tree.
It's like a whole
new experience to me.
I mean Billy's been successful in Sweden.
I haven't been in Germany. Um, Jeremy
you've things, I think I'm a bit weird.
They're like her hair and she's
done a weird mix and okay.
I did. Okay. That sounds bad. I don't want
to mix German. So it was like, you know,
they're not ready for
mixes. They are. Okay.
You're digging yourself. Oh
yeah, totally. Um, no. So this is
I think what, what we're not just
trying to say as well. It's like,
I mean do they like, they like I
think over here they, there is this,
I like the same thing in Sweden.
Like I think in America at least people,
you guys are really supportive.
Like you,
you see qualities in people
like strengths, like hurt,
like being very exotic.
First special is something that maybe
she had a hard time struggling with in
Germany, whereas here it's like
something that you go like, wow,
look at your stunning, you're
amazing. You're incredible.
So, so, so the, the you,
it's just different mentalities
from where you're from. But um,
at the end of the day, it's just the
same thing. I mean, we're actors and we,
you know, whether it's a small independent
movie from you in Sweden or, or it's,
you know, the, you know, this
monster of a, of a production.
It's like you just go there and you learn
your lines and you're like, all right,
try to make a good job.
And it's also like,
I mean,
how many of you ever dreamed about
winning the lottery? Like, right.
So you find people more than that.
So,
and then imagine one day
you really actually win the
lottery and then it's just,
you've been dreaming about it your
whole life and then you're like,
wait a minute now. It's, so, it's, it's,
it's, it really took a while. But like,
even today, like, like
still now I'm, it's,
it's been six months or we ever since
we stopped shooting the movie and like
seeing myself on a poster or like talking
to you guys and Google and in Chicago,
it's like, I'm still not, and I really
hope I'm never going to lose that.
I hope that hopefully even in
20 years I'll be, you know,
really thrilled about everything
I'm doing. And, um, so it's,
you don't get it and,
but it's just an amazing,
it's been such an amazing trip.
Yeah. No. Can you, congratulations. And
good. And speaking of that passion, not,
you talked a little bit about this on
why you were passionate into play, Anita,
but did either of you,
uh,
feel a deep connection with
your character? Did it,
did you feel like it was interesting to
play someone like you different from you?
How did you relate to those
characters you were playing with?
Oh yeah. You know, he's, he's, he's
very different. For me, I think Matthew,
but it's like anything,
I just,
for me it was like important to do
something just like, it's not a huge part,
but it's like, you know, I was just
want to do something that like might be,
you know,
a little new take on it for myself and
like creating something that's like
different from other things
I've done before and, and, and,
and make him feel like a real person
and, and, and come to life. Um,
and you only have yourself as tools,
like your own experiences and you know,
your face and you're at whatever,
like these are your tools that
you're given and then like,
what can you create from, from,
you know, with that. Um, um,
so yeah, you do find like,
okay, you know, you with anything
when you work, it's like,
how can I relate to this
scene? Like Blah, blah, blah.
And like how would I have done
it? And you know, then again,
like how would my character do it?
And then so forth.
I mean, I just described Nita
and if I be like, Oh, I'm Nita,
that would be kind of arrogant.
And Weird. Um, but it's definitely,
I mean, she suffered and I suffered
in terms of getting, I mean,
not suffering like tragedies,
but I got bullied in school a lot when I
was younger, um, because of the hair. Um,
so and I, and that made me stronger.
So I think that's, you know,
it just depends on when,
you know,
when you have a hard time life
either you're just, you know,
like hiding in the corner where you
just get up and become stronger.
And that's pretty much,
you know,
who Nina is and what
happened to her and Yup.
Thanks. That's very inspirational.
Thanks for sharing that. Um,
with that, um, you guys are welcome to
come up to the mics and ask questions.
We have one here on the right and one
on the left. So if you could please, uh,
start lining up. I'm sure these guys
would love to hear your questions.
It kind of would like to switch and
ask you guys questions sitting in an
audience.
Maybe we can take care of that afterwards.
I think that would be,
I'm sure these guys would love to hang
out and answer some questions about
Google. Um, so I want to make sure
we don't touch on any spoilers.
A allegiant comes out next Friday,
March 18th.
So now I touch you on spoilers about
this movie or even the next movie,
but you guys are here for the
rest of the series, right?
You're here for the third and
fourth movies. Yeah. Uh, what,
what are you excited about to see your
character's doing or growing as the story
progresses from allegiant
onwards in the series?
Well, I think that this
movie is, uh, you know,
part of it is like just
introducing this new element to it,
the new world that's outside of it and
where our two characters are part of it
and that, um, and you don't know,
like we haven't done the last one,
so we're sharing that in the
summer. So hopefully, um, you know,
but I'm looking forward to is like, you
know, exploring more cause I think I did,
you know, in terms of this movie being
like introduce like an introduction to my
character. Like, I would like hopefully to
have some things that play off and, and,
and the in the, in the last
installment of the franchise for sure.
Yeah. Well, yeah, we got introduced and
I would love to be able to show Anita is,
and the next one.
That's great. We're, we're
going to be looking forward
to that and waiting for it.
Yeah. Thank you. Thank
you for that over here.
Hi. Hi. Can you hear me okay?
I have two questions. One,
did he meet the author of the books
and then to have miles teller,
Theo James and Shailene Woodley.
Who was your favorite cast member
to work with and Theo James?
Like the most beautiful
man in the world. Yes, yes.
So,
um,
Shaline is one of the most beautiful
young woman that's ever met in my life.
She's just
very grounded and cares
about the world and you know,
things they're really matters. He
doesn't care about fame or money or any,
any like,
she's just like us.
We talk about toilet paper
and making soups and you know,
grocery shopping and um,
she's very inspiring to me.
And I'm Veronica Roth. I said that
before too, like when you hear the name,
you think of this, I thought of this like
60 year old, beautiful, you know, woman,
older woman would like red
hair and like big jewelry.
And then I met her on set and
she was this beautiful 26,
seven year old woman.
And um,
yeah, she's, she's great. And
Yeah, if you as a very handsome man
for sure.
Oh Great. Come on guys. Yeah. Yeah.
Hi,
I'm Joe from the tour.
At what moment did you realize that
you want to do, become an actor
for both of you? Um, um,
when I,
I never thought about acting because
no one in my family or no one in my,
you know, friends circle
I ever did it. So, um,
but this agent one day saw me
and she's like, you're an actor.
And I'm like, you're weird. You
haven't, you haven't even talked.
Like you tell me I'm an actor and she
would call me like every month at least
once and you know,
try to convince me and then I quit school
and then I called her and you can't.
Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, I come from an acting family
of access. So I got introduced to it, um,
very early on. And, um,
for me it was like, um,
I'm getting annoyed by myself cause
I repeat myself so much. But, um, uh,
like acting is for me as a kid was like,
I couldn't really believe that
you got paid for it. Like that.
I was an actual job, like, cause
kids, um, I mean we, we're,
we're all actors as kids, we play and we
perform and you know, like I am, you know,
the bad guy and you were
this guy on the cop.
I'm the superhero and you play with kids
and it's just as world of imagination
and,
and performance and characters and you
dress up and I'm a night or you know,
I'm a princess or whatever
it is. Um, and um, so for me,
like I was still on film sets as a kid
and like, I saw my dad, like, you know,
with a gun and a badge
and I'm like, what? Like,
who can play? And they're all adults and
they're still doing this, this, this,
this is ridiculous. And, um, um, um,
so I got introduced to it,
like,
just that part of playing was
just so fun for me. And then, uh,
I never grew up, so here I am. That's
awesome. Thank you both for being.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Over here.
Thanks for coming. Um,
I was curious about, um,
your accents, if you had to do some
sort of training for this or if, uh,
well, what was the training like if
there was one. And also, you know, if,
uh,
when talking to press in the u s you're
sort of still sort of making an effort
to stick with a particular,
uh,
American accent or it's just
become ingrained in your speech.
Uh,
well this is how I talk now.
So, um, and I don't know,
like I, I traveled, I was here
a lot as a kid growing up.
So, um, and then, um, I dunno.
So this is just how I talk.
Same here. I mean, I'm German.
Germans don't really sound like me.
Um, I was, I grew up
speaking French, German,
and French, so I think that my
posture is different. And, um,
I started watching
family guy when I was 15.
That's why she speaks like Peter
Griffin. Yeah. It's bad. It's bad.
Be careful because I mean the thing's
been on people, sand, family guy or not.
Yeah. Um, but um, yeah,
so I learned English from watching family
guy and friends and sex and the city
and all those great shows.
But also to answer your question, like
yes, we've both worked on it. Like,
Oh yeah man,
I got to a party,
no TV show couple of years
ago where I played in America,
which was my first American part.
Um,
so then you worked with a dialect
coach to sound American. Um,
and also for this one too, like we had
a, uh, a dialect coach, you know, um,
and you know, Theo James is
British, so he hasn't, you know,
someone of those solid
set all the time to, to,
to make sure that we sound
like we're from here.
Yeah. And she would like come
over and be like, I don't know.
And then you
do it differently.
Do you have any words that you,
I have trouble with something that is
kind of that thorn in your side and
pronunciation? Not really. I mean,
I definitely have to, I just,
I all said that before. Like, I mean,
I never spent more than five months
in this country. Like, you know,
I came out here in October and I've never
spent more time in the United States
then then now. And um, I'm sorry. Um,
so I, I just, I'm always very afraid
that I sound like a college girl.
I mean, I'm not college girls aren't,
it's not bad to sound like one,
but my vocabulary in,
in German is so much bigger and you know,
I could not talk to you about
politics or economy probably,
and that's a little bit
frustrating. But, um,
so if he's be in German to meet,
to find out that I'm okay smart.
Yeah.
That I'm smarter than I
sound. But yeah, for me
it was, um, a lot of the words, like we
don't have the t h sound, the Swedish.
Um, so I would have
problems with when you know,
where you would have like tea
that when you would go from a,
and also just this,
it's just so subtleties like you with
sound for and if you over pronounce things
too, like if you over pronounced
take things you sound for like,
it's just like,
so did you work on it to just sound lazy,
less lazy as an American?
Yeah. Hi. Um, I wanted to ask,
when you're acting,
there seem to be a lot of like three
dimensional CGI stuff going on.
What do you have to do differently as an
actor to be able to act out those type
of scenes as opposed to,
let's say regular scene without a lot
of three dimensional CGI going on?
Is there anything,
any special techniques or how do you,
how do you work with that?
Well, we've, we've gotten
that question a lot.
And the thing that people don't
realize is when we shoot a film,
even if it's a small little independent
movie and you're sitting and you know,
and just you and the scene is takes
place. It's just you and your, you know,
dying mom and then have this
bedroom. Um, there's still,
from where we see, there's like guy
holding the boom. There's just like,
there's so much going on behind the
camera that you as an actor pretend that
it's not there, even though you
don't see it through the Lens.
So when you don't see it through the Lens,
but you will add it in post,
it's kind of the same thing. It's like,
um, we don't, we know it's not there,
but we pretend it, that it is there.
And in terms of the film crew, we know,
we know they are there, but we
pretend that they're not so, so, um,
it's just this,
you know,
that sense of like imagine imagination
and just completely being true for the
scene. And it's a special thing
because you really don't see the,
the, you know, the crew members
standing behind the camera.
You don't see them at all.
And that's a special thing.
And it's the same thing where you're
like, okay, so this is, you know,
a plane come here is coming here and in
the scene you actually see the plane,
even though it's just like
a, you know, a laser point,
like the little dot that you're
following for eye line. It's, it's weird.
They want like also when, you
know, like that's saying, um,
dinosaur movies. Um, I mean there
aren't like real dinosaurs, but it's,
it doesn't really like when I,
when I have to act that, you know,
my boyfriend is dying.
I have to, you know,
make myself believe
that I love that person.
And I probably just met two days
ago and that now he's dying.
So that's the same imagination has just,
you know,
imagine imagining that there's a
t t t racks attacking me. So it's,
you basically just use your imagination
for everything and then you use your
imagination. Then you really have to make
yourself believe it from it, you know?
True. Coming from it. I'm
sorry, I'm, I'm a beginner.
Him coming from a true place and then,
yeah.
Yeah. Just, just like you said, Bell,
right? Like being a kid and just, yeah.
You're just playing.
Exactly. It's going back to
that whole thing. Yeah. Kids,
kids pretend and play and you know,
if there's not lava on the ground,
but you sure believe that it
is at the time when you're
playing. There's, there's,
there's rules.
Exactly. Well, thank you
both so much for coming.
It was great having you here for cargo
and we're excited to watch the movie on
the team. Yeah. The acting
thing doesn't work out.
Is there like a possibility?
I could maybe do an inches.
We have a lot of positions
available we can talk about.
I don't have any education though.
I speak French and German and English.
Your experiences is very
important to Google,
much more than what school you went to.
So we can
thank you both so much.
[inaudible].